hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today's video is going to be a
quick explanation of the difference
between centrosomes and centrioles
really quick remember to hit the
subscribe button and hit that bell icon
for notifications remember also that you
can get a free pdf of the final board
once all the notes are filled in you can
get that free pdf of the study notes if
you look in the description below and go
to that tiny url okay so let's go ahead
and get started
so central stones versus centrioles i
find that students often will
mix these up or even use these
terms interchangeably and they are not
interchangeable
so a centrosome
is a structure that is made up of two
centrioles
so the two centrioles
are oriented at
right
angles to each other that's 90 degrees
so they're basically perpendicular
each centriole is a structure made up of
nine
microtubules
now i have an entire other video on the
cytoskeleton
where you can learn about microtubules
microfilaments intermediate filaments
and their functions and structures so
check that out if you're interested
but here we've got each of these
uh centrioles made of nine microtubules
they're in a cylindrical array so that
just means that they kind of form like a
cylindrical type structure like a
cylinder
and their locations they're usually near
the nucleus in the cell
now they are only found in
animal cells and some protists so you're
not going to find centrosome composed of
two centrioles and plant cells they have
different um structures for organizing
their microtubules now if you're trying
to kind of remember wait what does the
centrosome do in the cell remember that
the centrosome is that microtubule
organizing center
it um well actually the centrosome will
duplicate itself during cell division so
that you'll have two centrosomes they'll
move to either side of the cell both of
those centrosomes will have two
centrioles and that's where the the
spindle the spindle array the mitotic
spindle grows from
to attach to the chromosomes and pull
them apart during cell division
now if you're still like yeah yeah yeah
center song centriole but i know i'm
gonna mix it up on the test then i've
got some helpful hints for you just to
remember which word is which thing so
for centrosome
think about the fact that it ends in the
word sum and in english the word sum
means you know more than one
and so if some means more than one you
can remember that the centrosome
is composed of more than one centriole
and specifically two centrioles right
and then for centriole the way that i
personally remember it i live in the
american south and
uh there are people who will talk about
oh you know it's just little old me
and so this old
right here i think of little old me
means just one so just um
you know we're talking about the a a
small thing a piece that makes up a
whole so the centrioles make up the
centrosome where some reminds us that
there's more than one involved there so
that's how i remember it
make sure that you get that tiny url
below to get the free study notes make
sure you subscribe
and i will see you next time for more
free biology study videos good luck and
thanks for watching